- Good evening, everyone.
And it is a good evening
because we are in it.
(audience applauds)
I am excited to be present at a gathering
where this community
acknowledges two people
in this business to whom I looked early on
while learning how to walk
in real women's shoes.
I am thrilled to be present
at such an historic moment
when this academy hails two men
who are brilliant storytellers,
and also my treasured friends.
I am beside myself that I
get to have the great fortune
to stand up on a glorious night
and say to you that I'm bearing witness
to the fact that Danny Glover shows up.
(audience applauds)
He always has.
He shows up.
He shows up to work, to
play, to build, to assist.
His strong hands and a tender reach.
He shows up.
That is why tonight we honor him
with the Jean Hersholt Humanitarian Award.
(audience applauds)
Marian Wright Edelman said,
"Service is the rent you pay for being."
It is the very purpose of life
and not something you
do in your spare time.
Danny's purpose-centered
life started early
at the direction of his parents,
James and Carrie, both postal workers,
when they brought their son
along to strategy meetings
and to the ground-shifting
marches of the Bay Area NAACP.
His mother had grown up
in Jim Crow, Georgia.
His father served with distinction
in the Second World War
where a black man could
die for his country
and often returned home only to die
at the hands of his countrymen
if he dared tried to live the freedoms
he had just risked his
life defending abroad.
In the Glover home,
dignity, respect, freedom,
and justice were the centerpiece
at the dinner table discussions.
They were the foundational values
from which Danny grew tall.
And he turned into a living
portrait of authentic activism.
It was a time of man when he
set out across the Bay Bridge.
It was the height of the
civil rights movement
and the fierce resistance to it.
Leaders who advocated that all men
and women were created equal
under the laws of Heaven and America.
Leaders who insisted America
deliver on her promise
to those upon whose backs
she was built and sustained.
Medgar, Malcolm, Martin,
and Bobby were viciously gunned down.
And Danny Glover stood up even taller.
He hit the books hard,
and he hit the streets with an insistence.
At San Francisco State,
Danny was a driving force
in the longest student
walkout in US history,
aiming to establish a
Department of Black Studies.
Why?
(audience applauds)
Because James and Carrie's
generation had fought
to get universities to
open wide their doors
to people of color.
And Danny recognized that higher education
was incomplete to a farcical degree
when it actively ignored
a crucial defining element
of American history and culture.
His activism helped create the
Department of Black Studies,
the first one in the United States,
along with the first
School of Ethnic Studies.
I have always gained strength
from standing shoulder
to shoulder with Danny.
Figuratively.
We bonded on film sets
with our shared history
of coming from good folk.
He brought me into the understanding
of the struggles of the
liberation of African peoples,
culminating in our co-founding
of Artists for a Free South
Africa to galvanize support
for a worldwide anti-apartheid movement,
and especially to be of
assistance to the leadership.
Nelson Mandela welcomed us.
He recognized us as his own
because our social activity was rooted
in a love for the people.
He thought Danny a comrade
because Danny walked
the walk of conscience,
even if it meant traversing a minefield.
Danny has been willing
to go to jail for justice
as he did in DC, protesting
at the Sudanese Embassy,
decrying the staggering atrocities
that created an intolerable
humanitarian crisis in Darfur.
For a man who moves with
love and delivers joy,
Danny is the poster guy
as a UNICEF ambassador,
and he's been actively
bringing hope, inspiration,
and healing in that capacity since 2004,
actually, it's since 1995.
He builds community
wherever his foot lands.
He levels his light
wherever a fellow traveler
pulls in darkness.
Danny Glover always does
the right thing first
without testing the prevailing
winds of public opinion.
The places in his heart
where he has put his time
and his resources outnumber his years.
Let's take a look.